en el último vídeo vimos que el bromo
hidruro de sodio reducirá aldehídos o
cetonas para formar alcoholes primarios
o secundarios y si vemos esta reacción
general esto puede ser un aldehído o un
acetona si añadimos hidruro de litio y
aluminio en el primer paso y luego una
fuente de protones en el segundo paso la
cual es agua formaremos un alcohol
primario o bien uno secundario
dependiendo de nuestros materiales
iniciales en ese sentido el hidruro de
litio y aluminio reaccionará de la misma
manera que el bromo y duro de sodio sin
embargo el bromo y bruno de sodio solo
reducirá adheridos o cetonas no reducirá
ácidos carboxílicos o ésteres y eso es
lo que hace el hidruro de litio y
aluminio podemos ver que si este de aquí
es un h eso sería un grupo funcional
card boxing
y si quitamos la h y ponemos un grupo al
kilo aquí en nuestro grupo principal
tendremos un tester el ídolo del litio y
aluminio no sólo reduce aldehídos y
cetonas también reduce ácidos
carboxílicos y estrés ya que es más
reactivo y es por eso que tenemos que
separar estos dos no podemos tener agua
en el mismo recipiente de reacción que
nuestro y duro de litio y aluminio
porque va a reaccionar con eso más
rápido así que una vez más nuestro
producto dependerá de nuestros
materiales iniciales
el mecanismo para la reducción de
aldehídos o cetonas con hidruro de litio
y aluminio es igual que el del boro
hidruro de sodio así que continuaremos
con el mecanismo para la reducción de un
esther así que hagamos eso empezamos con
un esther aquí abajo
tenemos a nuestro carbón y lo de esta
manera
pondremos nuestros pares libres y aquí
abajo tenemos nuestro grupo r prima así
ahí está nuestro esther y añadimos
hidruro de litio y aluminio en exceso en
términos de polaridad continuamos
poniendo hidruro de litio y aluminio
aquí abajo elegí más y luego tenemos el
aluminio unido a 4 hidrógenos de esta
manera y eso va a darle al aluminio una
carga formal de menos 1 así
el primer paso del mecanismo es igual al
que hicimos en el vídeo anterior bien
pensamos en el carbón y lo de aquí
arriba y en la diferencia en electro
negatividad entre este carbono y este
oxígeno el oxígeno siendo más electro
negativo jala estos electrones más cerca
de él esto le da una carga parcial
negativa mientras que el carbono de
abajo está perdiendo algo de densidad
electrónica volviéndose parcialmente
positivo el carbono carbónico es un
electro filo quiere electrones y por
supuesto va a obtener electrones de
estos dos electrones de aquí
estos dos electrones atacarán este
carbono bien así que tenemos un ataque
el núcleo físico y manda estos
electrones a nuestro oxígeno ese es
nuestro primer paso la porción de ataque
núcleo físico ahora tenemos r y ahora el
carbono solía tener dos enlaces con el
oxígeno ahora tiene sólo uno porque esos
electrones se movieron al oxígeno
dándole al oxígeno una carga formal de
menos 1 así añadimos nuestro hidrógeno
de esta manera y luego todavía tenemos
nuestro oxígeno y nuestro grupo r prima
por aquí
así que se verá así
en el siguiente paso de esta reacción el
carbón hilo se formará nuevamente por lo
que los electrones de aquí van a
regresar
acá para volver a formar el carbón y lo
eso significaría 5 enlaces al carbono lo
que sabemos nunca sucede por lo que
estos electrones van a tener que irse al
oxígeno
y continuamos dibujando los resultados
de eso ahora tenemos r unida a un
carbono volvemos a formar nuestro carbón
y lo ahora sólo tenemos dos pares de
electrones libres en ese oxígeno y luego
aún tenemos un hidrógeno aquí
bien perdimos un oxígeno con un grupo r
prima y ese oxígeno tendrá tres pares
libres a su alrededor con una carga
formal de menos 1
ya que el oxígeno es relativamente
electro negativo puede manejar esa carga
formal bastante bien y ser relativamente
estable ahora tenemos un aldehído
y sabemos que esta reacción puede
ocurrir otra vez con un aldehído ya que
tiene si duro de litio y aluminio extra
flotando alrededor lo que sucederá será
otra reacción cierto otra reacción como
la que acabamos de hacer tendremos
nuestro
y duro del litio y aluminio otra vez
esto es tan reactivo que no puedes parar
esta reacción una segunda vez y es la
misma idea cierto exactamente la misma
idea el oxígeno es parcialmente negativo
el carbono es parcialmente positivo el
carbono quiere electrones tomara estos
electrones de aquí estos electrones
atacarán este carbono
traerán el hidrógeno y luego estos
electrones se moverán al oxígeno
continuamos dibujando el producto de ese
ataque núcleo físico ahora tenemos un
grupo r aquí y tenemos nuestro carbono
unido a un oxígeno una vez más solía
tener dos pares libres ahora tiene tres
lo que le da una carga formal de menos 1
y este hidrógeno a la derecha se quedará
aquí y añadimos otro hidrógeno así
bien en el segundo paso de esta reacción
vamos a añadir agua volvamos aquí arriba
para refrescar nuestra memoria en el
segundo paso de esta reacción añades
agua como una fuente de protones
continuamos dibujando agua flotando
alrededor por aquí aquí está nuestra
molécula de h2o y vamos a obtener una
reacción ácido base tendremos un par
libre de electrones atacando y tomando
ese protón de ahí moviendo estos
electrones al oxígeno vamos a protón ar
este año en alcohol sido así que
finalmente formas tu alcohol
por fin acabamos ahora tenemos r y
después tenemos oxígeno unido a ese
hidrógeno de aquí ahora sólo hay dos
pares libres la carga formal se va y
puedes ver lo que hemos hecho aquí hemos
de hecho añadido dos hidrógenos a
nuestro carbono carbónico original bien
este es mi carbono carbónico original y
si lo veo aquí no hay un hidrógeno unido
a él aquí ambos hidrógenos vinieron de
nuestro hidruro de litio y aluminio este
y este por lo que la reacción ocurrió
dos veces bien si estás haciendo esta
reacción con ácidos carboxílicos es un
mecanismo similar no tenemos tiempo para
verlo pero terminarás con el mismo
producto
vas a añadir dos hidrógenos a ese
carbono carbónico origen
de esta manera
veamos la quimio selectividad de esta
reacción bien ahora que ya hemos visto
el boro hidruro de sodio y el duro del
litio y aluminio
veamos cómo puedes decidir cuál de estos
reactivos es mejor usar si empiezo aquí
con nuestros reactivos hagamos un anillo
de benceno así
bien continuas poniendo un doble enlace
aquí y luego haremos esto un grupo
funcional aldehído en un extremo y luego
en este extremo pondré
esther así
veamos cómo podemos transformar
selectivamente diferentes partes de esta
molécula utilizando diferentes reactivos
digamos que tenemos que hacer una
reacción en la que añadimos un boro
hidruro de sodio
y luego la fuente de protones
por lo que tenemos que pensar qué es lo
que va a suceder
el boro hidruro de sodio es para
aldehídos y cetonas únicamente no va a
reducir ácidos carboxílicos o ésteres
sólo reaccionará con el aldehído de la
porción arriba derecha de esta molécula
veamos si podemos dibujar esto aquí
va a reaccionar con el aldehído en la
porción de arriba a la derecha bien aún
tendremos nuestro doble enlace aquí
el al dedo se irá para formar el alcohol
primario por lo que obtendremos un
alcohol primario donde estaba el
aldehído
el bromo y truro de sodio ha reducido el
carbón y lo y en el segundo paso la
protón acción del alcor óxido forma tu
alcohol primario como tu producto y el
resto de la molécula se quedará de la
misma manera
este este va a permanecer igual aquí
abajo así que esta es la quimio
selectividad de esta reacción bien
digamos que empezamos con el mismo
material inicial y el primer paso
esta vez añadimos hidruro de litio y
aluminio así y en el segundo paso
añadimos un poco de agua
bien el hidruro de litio y aluminio
reducirá aldehídos y cetonas y también
va a reducir
esther es el hidruro de litio y aluminio
en exceso así que solo asumamos que está
en exceso aquí va a reaccionar con esta
porción de aldehído de la molécula
también va a reaccionar con esta porción
de esther de la molécula
así que reducirá a ambos y formará
alcohol continuamos dibujando el
producto aquí bien tenemos nuestro
anillo de benceno
que permanece igual
y aquí arriba
sabemos también que el hidruro de litio
y aluminio va a formar un alcohol
primario así
y luego ahí abajo lo que solía ser
nuestro grupo funcional esther vamos a
añadir dos equivalentes molares de
hidrógeno a ese carbón y lo íbamos a
terminar rompiendo ese enlace entre el
carbono carbónico y ese oxígeno todo
esto de aquí se irá como un grupo
saliente en nuestro mecanismo y vamos a
añadir dos hidrógenos a ese carbono
y luego eso va a formar un alcohol vamos
a añadir dos hidrógenos a ese carbono y
luego eso va a formar nuestro alcohol
así que vamos a añadir dos hidrógenos a
ese carbono formando un alcohol primario
aquí abajo también
igual que en el mecanismo que acabamos
de ver esta es la reducción de estrés
usando hidruro de litio y aluminio qué
pasaría si quisiéramos añadir gas
hidrógeno y paladio como nuestros
catalizadores bien esta también es una
reacción de reducción de la que hablamos
antes la hidrogenación es un ejemplo de
reacción de reducción y va a ser quimio
selectiva si solo utilizan las
condiciones normales para una reacción
de hidrogenación la única cosa que la
reacción de hidrogenación tocará es este
doble enlace
va a reducir este doble enlace así que
continuemos dibujando el producto no va
a tocar el ha leído no va a tocar el
éster y no va a tocar el anillo de
benceno continuamos dibujando el
producto el anillo de benceno no está
hidrogenado bajo condiciones normales y
el aldehído permanece igual aquí abajo
el esther va a permanecer igual también
así que eso sería nuestro producto de
una hidrogenación
tres reducciones diferentes tres
productos diferentes
ahora el hidrógeno reducirá a carbón y
los bajo las condiciones adecuadas
usualmente se hace aumentado la presión
y ha aumentado la temperatura
podrás de hecho reducir esos carbón y
los pero una vez más tú puedes controlar
estas condiciones
tú puedes controlar qué parte de la
molécula es reducida y eso resume las
maneras para reducir compuestos carbón y
los usando poro y duro de sodio e
hidruro de litio y aluminio en uno o dos
vídeos veremos los órganos metálicos y
particularmente el reactivo de griñón